look at them how did they get there if
it's crowd the answer must involve
Facebook and ahead of today's March anti
brexit campaigners have been plastering
Facebook with ads targeting select
audiences out advertising live groups by
as much as fifty nine to one give the
people the opportunity to have another
look at it
Sky News has seen a sample of brick
stood ads from the last two and a half
months often targeting specific regions
in the UK from Swansea to Edinburgh the
people's vote and best of Britain
campaigns cover the most ground leave
means leave and leave dot EU pop up far
less frequently with only one advert
aimed at Bolton the data comes from Sam
Jeffers who start up who targets me
collects political Facebook ads there's
a lot more advertising happening on the
remaining side at least from our data
and the users that we have who've
installed the software you know we're
not seeing a lot of stuff on the leave
side of things at the moment and you
know maybe that is a confidence on their
side that things are going the way they
want it to be or maybe those campaigns
haven't really got going yet for both
campaigns visibility is key but what
visibility means in politics has
fundamentally changed I see this ad you
see this ad but if it was on Facebook we
might see completely different versions
of it almost like different versions of
reality and that makes the democratic
weighing of arguments so much more
complicated Labour's former Director of
Communications once called for political
Facebook ads to be banned
now he's spending substantial sums on
them for the people's vote there's
definitely a war going on about brexit
and digital is one of the battlefields
of which were fighting we are doing it
because we have to and it's a good way
to reach people we need to reach now but
should political advertising on the
Internet
continue unregulated there's saw Wild
West no sir as a citizen rather than as
a campaigner no I don't think you said
today it was revealed that over 10
million British citizens may have been
targeted by an anonymous group calling
itself mainstream network
spent as much as two hundred and fifty
seven thousand pounds on pro brexit
facebook ads designed to pressurize MPs
like folk stands Damien Collins the very
man whose chairing the inquiry into fake
news into chucking checkers Facebook has
changed its rules to make ads more
transparent but when facebook ads can
help gather crowds like this
the temptation to manipulate it is gonna
get smaller and the challenges in
dealing with that aren't gonna go away
Branagh menthol Sky News